a major development this morning
resulting from an ongoing CBS News
investigation
it could affect more than 1 million Ford
Explorer owners the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration says the
number of complaints and injuries
related to possible carbon monoxide
leaks is much higher than previously
thought
Kris Van Cleave first reported on the
safety issue back in February he's in
Washington now with new details of the
government's expanding investigation
Chris good morning good morning
thousands of complaints have now been
filed with Nitsa and Ford about possible
carbon monoxide leaks and Ford Explorers
prompting Nitsa to expand its probe to
include 2016 and 2017 models like this
one this 2016 Henderson Louisiana police
explorer was badly damaged in a crash
after officers say its driver passed out
from carbon monoxide exposure in April
when she was treated at the hospital we
had requested testing for carbon
monoxide and her levels came out near
lethal yesterday that officer filed suit
against Ford and many more owners of
Explorers model years 2011 through 2017
are reporting carbon monoxide appears to
be seeping into their vehicles the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration now says more than 2,700
complaints have been lodged against the
automaker and 41 people have reported
injuries like Newport Beach California
Police Officer Brian McDowell who
crashed into a tree in 2015 after
passing out behind the wheel
I just went out just like that just like
that or sergeant Zachary LaHood in
Austin Texas whose dashcam was rolling
as he called for help LaHood was the
first of 18 Austin police officers to be
treated for carbon monoxide exposure the
city has removed 67 of its explorers
from service after they set off carbon
monoxide detectors the police union says
all 439 need to be off the streets now
this was not done by the end of the week
we're not big problems my officers are
worried about it in 2016
48 percent of law enforcement vehicles
were Ford Explorers departments across
the country have added carbon monoxide
detectors the Kansas Highway Patrol had
go off but it's not just police vehicles
the bulk of the complaints come from
regular for donors like Stacey Jones she
traded her 2014 Explorer in for a 2017
but says the problem didn't go away it's
frustrating because I at this point I
don't know what I'm gonna do
nitsa contends it doesn't have any proof
the injuries reported were caused by
carbon monoxide though investigators say
levels of that gas may be elevated
during certain driving scenarios ford
says safety is its top priority and has
a team working with police and
regulators to investigate reported
issues and solve them Chris thanks